im Landkreis Ravensburg in
Baden-Württemberg wird fleißig und
vorbildlich Biomüll gesammelt entsorgt
wird der aber nicht etwa in Deutschland
sondern im benachbarten Vorarlberg in
Österreich und um den Irrsinn komplett
zu machen wird künftig der Biomüll aus
Vorarlberg in den Landkreis Ravensburg
gekart verrückt die Umwelt wird wieder
belastet für eigentlich nichts also ein
LKW fährt in einer fährt zurück es ist
bekloppt also es ist jeder normal
denkende Mensch wurde sagen sowas macht
man nicht was ich jetzt weiß halte ich
das für einen großen Unfug und die
Kamera nicht vorstellen dass
intelligente Leute Verwaltungsleute
sondern fabrizieren
2013 schreibt der Landkreis Ravensburg
die Entsorgung seines biomülls
europaweit aus das günstigste Angebot
macht ein Unternehmen aus Lustenau in
Vorarlberg nach EU Recht muss es den
Zuschlag bekommen fortan werden ja für
Jahr Tonnen Biomüll per LKW von
Deutschland nach Österreich
transportiert
2022 schreibt der Gemeindeverband
Vorarlberg die Entsorgung seines
biomülls aus dieses Mal kommt das
günstigste Angebot ausgerechnet von
einer Firma aus dem Landkreis Ravensburg
die Folge künftig werden 18.000 Tonnen
Biomüll aus Österreich nach Deutschland
kutschiert im Ravensburger Kreistag
schlägt das ganze hohe Wellen
Tourismus zwischen dem Kreis Ravensburg
und dem Land Vorarlberg in Österreich
ist doch ein Stück aus dem Tollhaus das
ist ökonomisch unsinnig und ökologisch
schädlich sowohl der Gemeindeverband
Vorarlberg als auch der Landkreis
Ravensburg verweisen auf geltendes EU
Recht man haben nicht anders entscheiden
können schriftlich heißt es den Zuschlag
hat der Bieter mit dem
wirtschaftlichsten Angebot erhalten
Nationalität und Herkunft des Bieters
dürfen dabei nach dem EU-Vergaberecht
keine Rolle spielen
abenteuerlich Biomüll der unterm Strich
tausende Kilometer per LKW durch die
Gegend gefahren wird
stellt den Namen Biomüll auf den Kopf
Quatsch ganz große Quatsch auf jeden
Fall mal ist es nicht umweltfreundlicher
auf gar keinen Fall und also wenn alles
wieder auf die Straße verlagert wird ist
es nicht der richtige Weg ein Gespräch
aller beteiligten Behörden und Firmen
brachte keine Lösung jetzt will der
Landkreis Ravensburg fürs Jahr 2026 neu
ausschreiben so lange wird sich das
biomüllkarussell wohl noch munter
weiterdrehen